yes i can just bring you exactly what's
happened overnight in one residential
part of the capital you can probably see
behind me an apartment a residential
apartment building that has been
completely shattered by an explosion
we've spoken to residents here they said
that between 4 4 30 this morning they
were awoken to the sound of a huge
explosion they said that the night sky
lit up like daylight and then when the
dawn did break they found this
devastation to their apartment we
actually spoke if you look up onto the
second floor there the pink-coloured
wall um there used to be a balcony there
and we spoke to a lady called valentina
who lives there with her 19 year old
daughter she said to me that she had
been actually asleep um on that far wall
the far the far room where you can see
that bit of wood diagonally dangling
down she'd been asleep and said the
explosion blasted the window of the
balcony and the door across her
into the back of the of the room she
miraculously survived she's unhurt but
we were told by other residents that
some people here were taken to hospital
it's unclear exactly what happened but
one thing is sure there's an enormous
crater on the ground here
something clearly very big has exploded
into it one person said to me they
thought that it was a russian rocket was
being fired
in this direction and ukraine's air
defenses shot it out the sky and and
some of the shrapnel landed down but
that i'm no military expert but um i'm
not sure what caused that but clearly a
significant impact uh and you can see
bits of shrapnel in in that pit um but
this is one example of the collateral
damage of this conflict uh and this city
is uh is a city
at war in crisis the streets are eerily
quiet um and the the news that russian
troops are advancing is obviously making
every bit but a lot of people have have
moved already this explosion here has
prompted other families in this area to
leave we spoke to one
gentleman who was just packing up his
car with his daughter wife uh niece cat
and dog and they're getting out of the
city lots of people have left already
the schools are closed shops are shut um
here in this neighborhood you can just
see a lot of shocked people standing
around looking up at um at this ruin of
an apartment building and just very very
worried whether it could happen to them
next um it's it's a really really
unsettling time and it's hard to believe
that literally 48 hours ago this was a
city that was peaceful where shops were
open and people were enjoying normal
life and now especially here it's in
ruins and there's a lot of upset people
um shocked
and angry
valentina who we spoke to um was very
sure who to blame and she blamed
vladimir putin